there's a ton of terrible medical advice
online but some of the worst has been on
tick tock and by worst i don't always
mean just inaccurate i mean flat out
dangerous
butter ragu don't go together get that
dang in there
not only is that really not tasty the
saturated fat inside there that's
terrible the arteries are screaming i
feel it now this combo smack i gotta try
that smack white
how to stop your period for an emergency
what two shots of squeezed lime juice
tajin powder what is tajin powder salt
for flavor guys i had to come back to
give you an update because holy
guacamole no it doesn't have hormones in
it i don't understand how it could
possibly work the menstrual cycle does
experience regularities naturally like
if you travel if you're around other
individuals you can actually see
fluctuations a few days apart it's not
exact each month so the fact that she
had a one day difference in her
menstrual cycle i don't think it's due
to this like little tequila shot or
whatever it was that she took
oh synthol guy okay so this is literally
an oil that you inject in order to
increase the size of your muscle
bodybuilders sometimes use this please
don't do this you don't understand how
dangerous this is for your body like
vasculitis muscle rupture infection and
it's also ridiculous looking i don't
know if you see this
haters will say it doesn't work i'm
convinced that if you put a base
sunscreen of spf 30 on and then spf 90
on all the spots that you would put high
litter on the sun will contour your face
where you put bronzer and you will be
naturally snatching all summer check
this out you could put high spf
everywhere on your face and prevent it
from aging prematurely keep your skin
healthy non-sunburned and then you could
put makeup and make yourself as
beautiful and highlighter and
shaped and snatched as you wish to be
five organs five exercises to help you
restore those organ functions
please be medically accurate please
heart you're gonna pound inside these
are the nerves that are connected to
your heart these are the nerves that are
connected to your heart these are the
this is the skin this is the muscle and
there are nerves here that are not
connected to your heart what are we even
talking about right now
slap your arms slap it slap it slap it
you know what's a good exercise for your
heart
jogging
for your kidneys thrust for your kidneys
what just drink enough water stay well
hydrated sleep well get some exercise
and eat some plants and vegetables you
don't need to thrust
what is this a stretch
i guess she's using the dumbbells in
order to keep the legs stretched out i
actually have a lot of pain in that area
when i stretch so maybe i need to
improve my flexibility but remember too
much flexibility is not always the
answer and over stretching can actually
be a problem drinking sparkling water
isn't considered water
definition of water is fish must swim in
it
okay this is this is a saturday night
live skin sparkling water is not high
sodium but it is it has a deep mineral
content deep the depth of its mineral
content makes it not water
so best bat is always water first
definition of water is fish must swim in
it water first is a fine mantra but fish
must swim in it is ridiculous because
fish swim in salt water and if you drink
salt water oh boy you're gonna be in for
some troubles so i decided to go get a
colonic don't ask me the scientific
definition the scientific definition is
that you don't need a colonic that's
like the end of it oh my gosh this hurts
so bad it hurts don't do it they are
dangerous there is no benefit to them
people think it cleanses them out no
your body is a natural cleansing system
the surface
of your intestines regularly sheds and
leaves you don't have like poop buildup
that sits in there for years on end
what
i have a feeling this guy's russian
because he said oi and that's like a
russian thing but why is he hitting him
did he do something mean to his family
this is insane he's hitting him with a
mallet and a piece of wood on a napkin
this goes to show how bs this is so he
palpates the spine and then all of a
sudden he lifts his hands off and then
randomly applies the little pad and the
wooden thing my man you already let go
and you already don't see where you
palpated you're making it up you're
lying that vibe
honestly this is a crime i've never gone
as far as saying that on a tick tock or
any medical reaction video this is a
full-on crime there's a big difference
you do not inhale cigars okay it's just
a puff it never goes into your lungs
okay that's just like factually untrue
there's smoke all around you that you're
inhaling in fact secondhand third hand
smoke is really dangerous from cigars
cigars can even be more dangerous than
cigarettes chances of getting certain
types of cancers go up four to ten
tenfold so no they are not safer than
cigarettes that's just like a complete
myth you put garlic up your dough that's
supposed to cleanse your sinuses no they
don't cleanse your sinuses because
they're garlic so far there's a little
bit of snot trailing out around the
nostril holes so um if you're sick
you have snot
and that's what's happening i feel a lot
of congestion
right up in here because you plugged
your nose with the garlic
yeah that's all the snot that would have
come out had she not put those in there
it's an irritant to your nasal
passageways you don't need to do that if
you want to clear your snot out use
nasal saline this is a complete myth it
just does not work hey
what you doing dude i need a piece so
bad but these people have been in here
for like 45 minutes 45 minutes might
want to look elsewhere for a bathroom
you should start thinking about sex
really come on no dude i'm being serious
it tricks your brain and relieves some
of the pressure distraction when you
need to pee and you can't go in that
given moment works whether you think
about that whether you think about
what's going on next week will distract
you and allow you to think about
something else i want this migraine to
kill me come on stick your hands in this
ice water it'll help no just let me die
ice water okay fine fine ice for
migraines has been tested and has
found some relief and success in some
patients to me it's like a low risk
thing as long as you're not doing any
harm to your body and it could take some
of that pressure off and the headache
pain down by all means that's like a
really low risk way to try and do that
did you know that all the top athletes
are not drinking this stuff
what because i found out that gatorade
is actually very
very acidic you have lemon flavored
gatorade this right here actually
promotes inflammation promotes aging and
it promotes injury because once the body
goes acidic it cannot heal
the body keeps a very tight range of its
ph very tight 7.35 to 7.45 if it starts
gently coming out of that range and
becoming more acidic even slightly it
could be lethal so drinking gatorade
does not make your body go acidic
because if it drops your ph to below
seven every time you have a gatorade you
would be dead that's why health gurus
really frustrate me and confuse the life
out of me because on one hand they tell
you to take antioxidants like vitamin c
because they say they're so good for you
on the other hand they tell you to avoid
acid of any kind because it's so
dangerous do you know what vitamin c is
it's a sorbic acid
do you have a stuffy congested toddler
i'm gonna show you how to clear them out
blow out of one side of their nostril
make sure their mouth is shut
hold her mouth blow moms are so creative
cute video not the method i would
recommend use a suction tool like a bulb
pushing it out sometimes carries risk
you're moving bacteria around the airway
the child can choke on the snot plus
remember your mouth has a bunch of
bacteria in it that you're putting into
your child's mouth so suction is always
better in this scenario than blowing air
in this technique does work sometimes
breathing in a child's mouth if your
child has something stuck in their
nostril closing the other nostril
breathing into the child's mouth for me
if something stuck in your child's nose
go to the er like that's the safest way
to get it out
that looks like a keloid scar basically
a keloid is after you get any kind of
damage to your skin cuts punctures etc
you could actually form excess collagen
in the form of a keloid like this uh it
does happen in younger people more often
like ages 10 to 30 darker skin
individuals have 10 to 20 percent higher
rates of this as well why does a hot
bath burn more belly fat than jogging
for an hour it doesn't imbalanced
hormones
hey my name is dr jade tita and you're
probably thinking to yourself what is a
big burly linebacker looking guy like me
my man have you seen a linebacker
women looking to lose weight especially
in their midsection may want to pay more
attention to foods and activities that
balance hormones based on their unique
hormone type and he's going to sell you
exactly what their unique hormone type
can benefit from take my unique hormone
type quiz because a hormone type 2 needs
a different approach a hormone type 2
that i just made up than a hormone type
6.
my man said type six what happened to
one three four and five and seven
i i wanna be smart enough as a doctor to
come up with my own hormone types
you definitely want to sanitize the area
before you do any kind of micro needling
that's smart
if you're going to be making abrasions
in your skin so much can go wrong
especially on the face i just wouldn't
trust a random device bought off the
internet kind of felt like getting a
tattoo had only a couple spots that bled
just a teeny tiny bit people really
trust these things being a family
medicine doctor not a plastic surgeon or
a dermatologist when a patient comes in
with even a small laceration that
requires sutures on the face i'm always
hesitant to do it because i want to make
sure that it's as less scarring as
possible happening so i let someone with
a lot more experience do it these people
are just like
doing micro needling on themselves with
no fear
oh not ear candling there's a warning
from the fda to not do this
so this is bs because this has been
tested and we actually see no suction
happening as a result of the flame we
also see that that is
residue of the actual paraffin wax or
beeswax that is inside this candle thing
because we see the same residue on these
candles that have not been put into ears
on top of that do you know how many of
my colleagues have treated burns from
this earwax nonsense oh my god
life-saving advice from movies that can
actually kill you according to hollywood
if someone is passed out with no pulse
you should straddle them give them mouth
to mouth and beat on their chest yeah
don't beat on people's chest don't give
them mouth to mouth if someone's passed
out all you have to do is chest
compression test compressions testing
pressure i'm not saying cpr doesn't work
but it only works like two to four
percent of the time and when properly
performed you usually end up cracking
the person's rib cage my man is confused
here because he's saying pounding on
their chest versus performing chest
compressions is both cpr factually
untrue the purpose of performing cpr is
not to bring someone back it's to buy
time so other interventions can be done
by giving them medications like
epinephrine or perhaps bringing a
defibrillator along because the reason
you're pumping on someone's chest is to
circulate the blood that's already in
their body that has some oxygen still
left in it and the breaking of the ribs
no big deal why because the person is
already dead so if you can extend their
possibility of being brought back to
life by breaking a rib fair trade-off
wouldn't you say
beating up misinformation or beating up
other boxers click here announcing my
boxing career right there click it i'm a
serious boxer getting better with each
day who's gonna be my first fight leave
a link down below leave a comment down
below don't know what i'm saying stay
happy and healthy
[Music]
you
[Music]